[Applaudissements]
mes premiers souvenirs d'entreprise
remonte à mai six ou sept ans je vais
partager avec vous une photo
à cette époque avec mon grand frère
nous étions ravis quand notre père le
mardi soir
arrivé du travail et le budget les gars
demain matin je vous emmène dans mon
camion
mon papa travailler dans un abattoir de
volailles de challans et ainsi nous
l'accompagnons et des trois heures du
matin et je me souviens encore de ces
moments de complicité avec mon grand
frère mon père ces odeurs de ferme
ces odeurs de fiente de poulet et de
chocolat chaud que nous servait la
fermière avant que nous repartions pour
ramener la volaille vivante à l'abattoir
que vous apercevez derrière moi de ses
souvenirs candide cet abattoir nous a
réservé une autre réalité chez plantive
quand on voulait quelque chose est bien
fait qu'on se le paye et pour ce pays
fait travailler alors nous avons avec
mon grand frère travail et petits
boulots d'abord et puis les saisons et
je me souviens le matin nous arrivions à
l'abattoir à 5h 6h
je me souviens encore des néons agressif
je me souviens du bruit incessant de la
chaîne
cette relation à la mort cette odeur des
viscères de sang et puis la pause de 10h
la pause de 10h le casse croûte et dans
le vestiaire on parlait potager on
parlait pêche chasse très peu
d'entreprises mais les gars comme on les
appelait était heureux de leur destinée
et mon frère et moi nous étions partagés
sur deux grands sentiments un sentiment
d'admiration parce qu'à l'époque nous
étions en pleine force de la nature tous
les deux tennisman et puis quand on
disait qu'on avait travaillées on savait
qu'on avait une certaine robustesse
que nenni ces ouvriers
il avait une force incroyable leurs
mains étaient de véritables outils de
précision et nous ne posions pas lourd
dans la balance par rapport à leurs
propres capacités
nous avions donc ce sentiment
d'admiration
mais aussi un sentiment
d'incompréhension
comment pouvions-nous travailler de la
sorte remettre le couvert tous les jours
pendant 20 ans 30 ans 40 ans
mon frère et moi nous savions pourquoi
nous faisions des études nous voulions
accrocher notre avenir a une autre idée
les études pas forcément très brillante
nous concernant toujours peut mieux
faire
commencez à machecoul poursuivi à notre
dame
par la force des choses à challans
et puis la joliverie et puis les
premiers stages en entreprise et puis à
ce moment là j'apprends ce que c'est que
l'entreprise d'un point de vue théorique
la société du latin sociaux ce compagnon
j'apprends que lorsqu'on veut devenir
entrepreneur il faut créer sa société
l'enregistrer au greffe du tribunal
ainsi fait on vous demande de définir un
objet social de constituer un capital
social composé de parts sociales
et puis moi devant vous je suis une
personne physique mais la société que
vous créez c'est une personne morale
très intéressant comme thématique le
social le moral chemin faisant dans les
différents stages j'arrive du côté de
saint-herblain côté de nantes et je fais
la connaissance d'un homme qui dirige
son entreprise différemment de ce que
j'avais vécu dans mes autres stages et
bien sûr dans la destinée familiale la
première chose qu'on me dit est ce que
tu connais l'informatique je ne
connaissais rien à l'informatique pour
moi ma connaissance c'était surtout le
poulet
et on me dit dès le départ
la première chose que tu feras en
rentrant dans l'entreprise thut saluera
tout le monde et on me dit bien sûr le
tutoiement est de rigueur
là les codes étaient déjà très différent
de ce que j'avais pu rencontrer ailleurs
je suis devant vous et il y a donc 25
ans j'ai intégré cette entreprise je
suis passé par l'ensemble des métiers du
commerce
il a fallu déterminer le successeur du
fondateur ce capitaliste soixante
huitard comme on l'appelle souvent mais
pour avoir légitimité pour succéder à un
tel homme il fallait en passer par un
vote
et donc j'ai été élu pour lui succéder
cette entreprise c'est une recette de
cuisine les valeurs les ingrédients
plein de valeurs je vais en décliner 3
devant vous
la première la valeur de partage premier
ingrédient deuxième ingrédient le
respect et le troisième agrément
ingrédients la transparence je voudrais
partager une autre photo avec vous ce
soir
on est au travail la valeur de partage
le partage c'est bien entendu partager
le quotidien partagé le travail travail
partagé bien sûr les bons moments comme
vous les voyez derrière moi mais c'est
avant tout pour nous c'est partager le
capital ce fameux capital social lorsque
vous intégrer l'entreprise dès la
signature de votre cdi
vous êtes libre dès la première année
d'investir dans le capital l'objet s'est
enraciné donner du sens c'est bien
entendu gardé l'indépendance garder sa
destinée en main et puis ce capital il
doit se transmettre
nous l'avons défini ainsi ainsi un
collaborateur
puisqu'on parle de collaborateurs et
bien lorsqu'il a 50 ans il est à 15 ans
de la retraite à 50 ans non seulement
vous ne pouvez plus acheter de capital
mais chaque année jusqu'à votre retraite
vous céderez un quinzième de votre
détention en parts sociales
vous allez me dire mais pour qui pour
les moins de 50 ans ainsi chaque année
il y à une bourse aux actions et chaque
année les plus jeunes rachète aux plus
âgés premier ingrédient le partage le
deuxième ingrédient c'est le respect je
voudrais partager avec vous cette photo
le respect c'est bien entendu le respect
de l'autre que nous soyons bac +2 à bac
+5 nous avons aussi des bacs plus est
que nous soyons personnel d'entretien
ingénieurs ou dirigeant respecté le
travail qui est fait par l'autre parce
que nous partageons la certitude que
chacun apporte sa pierre à l'édifice le
respect c'est aussi l' équilibre pour
nous en tout cas des rémunérations ainsi
souvenez vous il y a quelques années un
président de la république avait
souhaité faire en sorte que dans les
entreprises publiques et parapubliques
la différence entre le plus bas salaire
et le plus haut salaire soit contenue
sur une échelle de vingt
dans notre entreprise nous appliquons
une échelle de 3 entre mon salaire est
le plus bas salaires partant du principe
qu'il n'y a pas de sous tâches ou
dessous qualification bien entendu que
les bas salaires sont beaucoup plus haut
qu ailleurs certainement aussi que mon
salaire est plus bas qu'ailleurs
le médian est conforme à la profession
nous attachons nos collaborateurs à une
très grande motivation là encore après
l'enracinement du premier ingrédient
troisième ingrédient la transparence je
voudrais partager cette photo on
aperçoit pas très bien dans le fond
c'est une assemblée générale il ya du
monde à l'assemblée générale
autant que ce soir
cette transparence et la transparence
des chiffres c'est la transparence de la
rémunération
tout le monde connaît ce que gagne tout
le monde
ainsi il n'y a pas de rumeurs dans
l'entreprise tout le monde détient les
règles cette transparence et savoir
organiser le liant entre la vision du
conseil d'administration et puis la
réalisation du quotidien dans chacune
des équipes
il nous a fallu inventer
des couches intermédiaires de management
nous en passons par l'élection et ce à
chaque année des personnes qui composent
ces couches intermédiaires de management
la légitimité est en marche
chaque collaborateur a eu la possibilité
de choisir son chef
nous avons inversé les tendances je
voudrais enfin partager cette dernière
photo à l'occasion de nos 20 ans puisque
l'entreprise a précisément 22 ans nous
avons les conjoints de nos
collaborateurs ainsi que les enfants il
apparaît comme une évidence que nous
connaissons une véritable mouvance vers
la détention d'entreprise très éloignés
de ceux qui produisent via des
organismes financiers
l'aco détermination que nous avons
déterminé chez pro dans l'entreprise
merci
elle vient du fait que chaque dirigeant
parmi les 12 du conseil d'administration
sont tous opérationnels en caux
détention de l'entreprise souvent on
nous a dit pour les sceptiques
ça ne peut pas fonctionner comme modèle
il faut bien des gens pour des jeunes
pour diriger le conseil d'administration
et pour les là pour ça il détermine la
vision les sceptiques aussi nous disent
vous êtes dans l'informatique c'est
normal ça fonctionne c'est un secteur
d'activité qui se porte très bien le
secteur de l'informatique précisément en
france en moyenne chaque année croît de
5 %
ce cas remarquable notre entreprise est
en croissance à deux chiffres depuis sa
création il ya 22 ans qui est de la
poule ou de l'oeuf
une certitude nous habite c'est que nous
sommes jugés non pas sur ce que l'on lit
ou sur ce que l'on peut être amené à
dire comme moi ce soir devant vous nous
sommes jugés sur ce que l'on fait et
nous le faisons et ce qui est formidable
c'est que nous sommes certains que faire
du copier-coller d'organisation humaine
entre organisations humaines c'est
extrêmement compliqué mais nous
partageons déjà ses convictions
profondes avec d'autres dirigeants dans
des entreprises beaucoup plus petite que
la nôtre dans des secteurs d'activité
qui n'ont rien à voir
et ça fait taire les sceptiques en
boulangerie par exemple et à chaque fois
ces entreprises connaissent le même
mouvement la même dynamique
je crois qu'il est essentiel de ne pas
s'arrêter sur les normes ne pas
s'arrêter sur le consulting aveugle de
ne pas s'arrêter sur les labels pour
faire bien sûr un site internet de bien
vivre au travail
le bien-vivre travail ce n'est pas
mettre simplement un flipper dans une
salle à café c'est beaucoup plus profond
que ça
notre conviction c'est qu'il faut aller
chercher avant tout l'harmonie entre les
hommes et les femmes
merci
[Applaudissements]